he's Adam Schefter the ESPN NFL insider
who joins us on loan from the mothership
good morning Adam how are you good
morning Dan how are you doing we're
doing great I want you to walk me
through the call that or if it was a
call or a text with Andrew Luck but I
was curious prior to that phone call or
tweet whatever it were text whatever it
was did you have any indication about
Andrew Luck's immediate future with the
cult well let me just say this damn
basically as I've said to a couple of
the people of best service stories that
you work on for days or weeks require a
lot of calls and a lot of time and a lot
of energy and some of them come together
and some of them don't and then there
are other stories that are fast-moving
stories that just come together quickly
this was one of those that came together
quickly for a variety of reasons it
wasn't like on last Monday I had a
premonition that Angela could be
retiring that he was having the actual
talks that he was with the members of
the cult organization this all kind of
came together quickly and caught me as
off-guard as caught everybody else was
there any thought to not breaking it
during the game I don't understand that
I really don't I I look you did it and
you're supposed to that's that's your
job but I'm just curious if you've
thought about that he's there and all of
a sudden this this doesn't become a
football game anymore Dan number one I'm
at a surprise birthday dinner surprise
75th birthday dinner for my
mother-in-law I apologize for not
tracking where and when the whole severe
it was when the information is coming in
to me yeah that's number one number two
as you mentioned that is my job when I
get news number three there have been
any number of stories that I've sat on
over the years I you know somebody's
asked me to wait you're can you just
wait till I notify the player of this
trade or the coach nosy being fired or
hired or whatever it may be before you
report it and you know listen every
circumstance is different you manage
these relationships the best you can
while maintaining the integrity the job
and doing your job do
you wonder about that that you were
getting this information when you got it
from your source that why were they
giving it to you at that point no I look
I got the information I never stopped to
think boy I wonder what part of the game
they're in I wonder if this should be
disruptive I wondered how am I gonna get
disconfirmed
am I gonna give people a heads up which
I did I called a couple of different
people within the Colts organization to
let them know that I'm gonna be
reporting the story nobody picked up
nobody got back to me somebody could
call me back and said hey you know we're
in whatever part of the game we're in
would you mind waiting already met
nobody did that and I report it when I
felt comfortable with the information
which I would do a hundred times out of
a hundred over again I and again then
the owner GM and head coach of the Colts
organization knew last week
Andrew knew last week yeah Andrew told
teammates on Thursday Andrew told
teammates on Friday they discussed as an
organization having the press conference
on Friday or Sunday at 3:00 I don't know
why they waited to push it off to Sunday
through but they did that was their
decision and again this is a sad story
and it's unfortunate for Andrew for the
Colts for the city of Indianapolis for
football and Gentiles an unbelievable
player nobody wants to see them leave
the game but when there are that many
people who know frankly I am shocked
that it didn't get out sooner yeah I am
too when you start to hear that
somebody's telling somebody who then is
gonna tell somebody and hey don't tell
anybody but and correct yeah and so when
eventually some of that makes its way to
me I you you really think I'm saying oh
I know this is big and it's gonna
surprise people I know this fantasy
football dress going on across the
country right now and people are
drafting and I know that there's a game
but I'm just gonna wait for Andrew to
make the announcement is Adam Schefter
from the mothership joining us is their
language if he turns in his retirement
papers then
then if he decides to come back what is
the process for Andrew Luck that's a
great question i-it'll come up look the
Colts put him on the reserve retired
list so he's there right yes they have
his rights if he wanted to play I guess
they could remove him from that list and
the contract would come back into
existence though they negotiated that
settlement where he got to keep the
twenty eight point four million dollars
that was paid to him in the form of
bonus money twelve million dollars in
March and so I don't know the exact
process other than the first key step
would obviously be Andrew having to
decide that I do want to play again and
of course that conversation will come up
just as it came up for Barry Sandra's
just as it came up for Calvin Johnson we
know it's going to come up in
conversation you know regarding Angela
whether he actually does it or not who
knows
honestly it's just way too early to say
like he's done with football right now
and he may be done with football forever
that that's very possible but it may be
that a year from now it's your scenario
decides you know what I missed this but
he's a unique guy he's a very deep
thinker I I don't know that any of us
could predict what he is or isn't going
to do but the Colts did what they had to
do to control his rights in the event
that he does decide to come back they
have his rights he'd have to make the
decision they take him off the list and
we go from there I'm curious you know
you said you were at this birthday party
you know what's the strangest place
where you've ever broken his story that
would be that would be one where
literally I've never had this happen
where I'm on the streets of Piermont in
New York Dan at an Italian restaurant
and you're following the story and you
have waiters and Busboys coming up and
asking you is it true do you just report
this I mean it was it was a you know it
was a surreal scene for the cults it was
a surreal scene for me I you know I got
a quote from a GM he was leaving a
baseball game and he said that his wife
said to him that I'll always remember
being at this game and hearing where I
was the moment that we heard that Andrew
Luck was retiring I you know I do think
it was one of those moments that
I remember where I was with magic
Johnson announced that he had the AIDS
virus and we can retire from basketball
you know and and I I think that due to
the unusual circumstances of this story
and how great Andrew Luck is and was III
think it's one of our stories the people
love them I know I will always remember
where I was when that story got out tear
money or confetti between the bruschetta
founded by Busboys and waiters it was
true that's great you're breaking a
story in a restaurant and then those
guys working in the restaurant know that
you're breaking it so they just walk out
and ask you the question is this true I
love that hey can you tell me what the
the long-player swordplay is in Dallas
with Ezekiel Elliott because it feels
like Jerry Jones is almost bracing
himself for the fan base that hey you
know what we want him back when we
really need him as far as you know maybe
don't expect him that first week I just
think this I think that if I were a
businessman and I were on the Zeke
Elliott side whether I was one of his
representatives or Zeke himself I would
know that I was in for the match of a
lifetime Jerry Jones is probably not the
guy you want to be squaring off against
in a business negotiation I don't know
too many people have been successful
negotiating deals against Jerry Jones
and again Zeke has got leverage in the
form of his services and they haven't
had any talks in recent days but it's
the kind of thing that could come
together really quick I mean they could
get this deal done in a few hours if
they wanted and they're not close to
doing that at this point but at some
point whether that's today Monday next
Friday after the Cowboys play game these
two sides are going to sit down and
hammer out that deal but I just think
that the Cowboys are where they are
they're going to be tough to move off
this and it's a question of when Zeke
wants to decide to come play now if I'm
wrong and they get to deal of a lifetime
and they shatter the market todd gurley
set from the Rams then good for them
then they've done an unbelievable job
just think that Jerry Jones is going to
stand
he's offer and stick to his guns and
again like I said it's not easy to be
Jerry Jones in a negotiation Adam thanks
for joining us always great to talk to
you we appreciate your time thank you
Dan have a great season we'll be in
touch all right Adam Schefter yes Penn
NFL insider for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]